so what's going on amanda how can i help
i am married me and my husband we've
been married for a little over three
years now
we have an 11 month old baby boy um
i i do have some postpartum depression
and postpartum anxiety that i'm dealing
with um
but you did have a baby in a global
pandemic right
yes oh mercy yeah okay
that's the other most southern thing oh
mercy hey
you've earned your postpartum so
man god bless you that's a tough tough
season to have
a young one and so blessings to you all
right so go ahead
i found out in early december um
a complete shocker my husband
had improper contact with a minor at our
church
and i'm having trouble dealing with the
aftermath of that
with the church with the other family
involved
and just moving forward with this
situation
when my husband comes home i i'm just
i'm at my wit's end and
i feel like i just i don't know what to
do
yeah that's a lot all right so walk me
through some of the particulars here
and this is a highly sensitive situation
and so you at any moment say i don't
want to talk about that part
okay is that cool sure absolutely
or here's a better way to say it you're
in 100 control of this narrative and so
at any moment
you can bow out okay is that cool yeah
okay so when you say inappropriate
contact with a minor
what does that mean how old what was the
inappropriate contact
walk me through that sure
the girl is 13 years old i found out
that
he held hands with her at church one
wednesday night
says no sexual contact happened he says
no
sexual contact happens so um
hopefully that not reduces some of this
but i guess
it doesn't make it even harder um well
holding hands with a 13 year old is
sexual contact
um oh okay maybe they didn't touch
it with kids we call it bathing suit
parts right so
like any part that's covered up by a
bathing suit is off limits but
what was the situation where somebody
would how did that
what's the narrative that how they ended
up holding hands
sure um what happened was
the girl's dad uh helps operate the
sound booth at our church
and uh controls the the tech side and
he wanted to learn how to work it as
well so that way
um not just one person is stuck doing
that
and there can be a rotation and she was
back there as well
um with with her dad um
and she and of course this is no
justification
whatsoever it's just me trying to gain
a remote sense of understanding um
she was kind of making moves at him
um where she was hiding her lips
not a thing not a thing at all
because she's a child don't even go
there in your head okay
don't even go with your head i know you
want to protect your husband and more
importantly you want to protect your
sanity right now
okay yeah i don't care if that 13 year
old
threw herself at him sent him a bunch of
inappropriate pictures i don't care
what that child did the adult in that
situation
is the adult in that situation right
absolutely 100 okay so go ahead
so she she was um
i don't even know what to say she's a
kid um he felt as though he was
she was being provocative um
in a sense and then he said that um
he he was just thinking about a
former void in his teenage life that
was unfilled due to trauma and he just
needed
words of affirmation and a kind touch
from a kid yep
yeah dude
man amanda i don't get mad very often
and
um yeah i'm pretty close so what was the
church's response here
um of course um when
when this was found out um we had a
meeting
with the deacons um there there are five
of them at the church
um the girl's parents and then my
husband was present at the meeting
i was on speakerphone because you know
i'm i
someone has to be home take care of our
son
so the decision was was that
he needed he needed to go to intense
therapy
or the dad was going to immediately go
to the police
and and file a police report and have
you know my husband
go to jail uh you know right rightfully
so for it
so hold on hold on hold on hold on oh
gosh dude man so the church didn't call
the police they didn't call a social
worker they didn't get
the authorities involved no
it pisses me off so bad so bad
oh man amanda i'm sorry uh i'm not sorry
i know my anger's not at you my anger is
at church is covering up stuff like this
which is how it perpetuates and goes on
and on
and on and on and it communicates to
teenagers
that adults aren't held like responsible
in the appropriate nuclear option which
is what should happen in these moments
oh my gosh okay so
man
i'm singing for a second is that cool
amanda oh
sing away i'm sure you're saying my
mercy too
right so yeah long story short um
my blood pressure's getting up and i'm
gonna get that uh
man i don't think i've ever gotten super
pissed off on the radio
um maybe i have i don't remember not
like this
um so what's your ultimate question
let's just get to that
sure um well sin since this
has gone on um my husband did go to
therapy
um he he checked himself into
a place called the ranch it's you know
outside of nashville yeah i know about
it and uh
so he he's there right now he's in the
sex addiction program
hold on is he a sex addict
uh yes yes so is he a pornography ad
does he have lots of affairs
um he has never had an affair but
uh pornography addiction yes
so he's never had an affair but he
claims he's a sex addict
uh yes so i've heard
the fall to my knees
save me i'm so sorry i'm an addict
excuse
often in the last decade 20 years
um the sex addicts i've known the sex
addicts i've
i have several of my mentors
and professors were actually like
they were
they were trained therapists that worked
with people with sexual behavior
disorders
and true sex addicts
man they they they don't have unaffair
it's a way of life it's the way i eat
gummy candies
it's pathological right um
anyway that's not what you called um
i have a hard time believing somebody
and me and maybe there's a medical
doctor out there or a psychologist that
overrides me and they can override me
all day long i'm not going to go to war
with them on that but i have a hard time
um signing up for somebody who's a sex
addict who um
instead of saying that there's somebody
who made awful terrible disgusting
decisions
and needs to be criminally held liable
for what they're doing
or at the very least not around kids
um yeah yikes okay so he's in rehab now
he's in rehab um because he held hands
with a 13 year old
and is he getting out soon i guess if
this is early december so he's coming
out
next whenever right yeah
by the end of this month okay so can i
can i um
just make a guess here
in the have you all been allowed to
usually there's a few weeks of no
contact
and then there's just limited you know
drip by drip contact have y'all started
reconnecting again
uh yes he he gets one 20-minute phone
call every other day
okay so i'm just gonna take a wild guess
here
you are not gonna believe amanda how
much i've changed
the things i've learned about myself in
my past and my childhood are so big and
so deep and it's
amazing and i can't wait to be around
you and the baby because
everything is clear now i understand
and it's so incredible how much i've
grown and i'm better
am i close yes
like right hitting the nail on the head
oh
yeah you're like 99
yeah so what are you going to do
what do you want to do um
let me let me back up i think you know
exactly what you want to do
i think you're an extraordinary good
person
i think you're a um are you a christian
yes okay so you have a christian ethic
about you you've got a way of
being you've got a picture of what your
marriage and this new little baby was
gonna be how old are you
um i'm 33. okay so you had a you're 33
you've waited for this you've got a
husband who
was participating a guy who helped at
the sound booth in church right so you
had this picture
and now it's an ash right yes
completely and the temptation is to try
to just pick up all this ash in a bucket
and start trying to duct tape it back
together think of it like the twin
towers
if they went and swept up all that glass
and dust and
twisted metal and steel and tried to
rebuild it with that those materials
you can't do it so any relationship you
have with this dude moving forward
is after this
okay and that is hard to hear i can't be
the first person who's told you that
but it's hard to hear i know um but
moving forward trying to reclaim this
picture
it is no more okay gotcha
um your church quite honestly let you
down
your husband let you down um
the whole thing's a mess and i'm so so
sorry amanda
oh well thank you i know i didn't i
didn't help you i know
um you know what you want what you need
to do you know what you want to do
what just for my own sanity and for the
listeners here
what do you think the next month looks
like for you
i think in the next month he'll come
home
and for a few days he will be a
completely
transformed person but then little by
little it'll
revert back and um
it it'll just go back to where it
started
you know just you know any kind of
progress is just
unraveled because you know he he gives
me a whole list of things that he wants
to change
and and everything and how life wants to
be
and he's going to follow the 12 steps to
a t
and um i have a feeling that being out
in the real world
that he'll he will real like recognize
how hard that actually is and
um i don't know if he's if he's up for
the challenge of
making such a huge change in his life
you know for for such a long period of
time because it
you know it that would be a hard thing
to even attempt to
you know cut come back from i mean
there's so much depth to it from from
what i'm understanding and so i
i just have a feeling that he'll get out
do well for
a little while and then crash and burn
do you have somebody who's walking
alongside you through this
yes okay so
um i'm just a guy on the radio
okay all right so i'm not gonna tell you
what to do
i'm gonna tell you what i would do in my
house
okay um nope i'm gonna tell you what i
would tell my sister
i'm gonna tell you what i would tell a
best friend of mine
who was a co-worker who was a woman in
the same situation
okay
if you've got 11 month old in your house
somebody getting out of rehab whatever
that's supposed to mean for this
situation
after 28 days is not coming back to my
house for a season
okay i would tell my sister not to let
that happen i would tell my wife
um well i'm married to her so that'd be
weird but
um i i would tell the close friends of
mine
in my life that are married women with
small kids that
that would not be a wise decision um
i would in my opinion
your church leadership has proven
themselves to be not worth following
i wouldn't go back to that building and
i know that's hard
and i know that you've probably got deep
relationships there
but they let you down they let that
little girl down
they let that 13 year old girl down they
let her family down they let that
congregation down
and it's disgusting um but at the end of
the day i would not have somebody just
pop back into my house
without some very serious
couples counseling without somebody
walking alongside you
both a friend and a professional if not
a couple
and without a very very clear plan on
your part about what it's going to look
like
to be well what it's going to look like
to be welcomed back in this house
okay now if you've ever listened to this
show you know that i am all about
redemption i think it's
deep and i think that there is not a
lost person
i also don't mess around with people who
hurt kids
i just don't and so
can you and him reconcile and can he
change his life i believe so i wouldn't
be sitting in this chair i wouldn't be
doing this job
is it going to be a hard messy ugly
bumpy road yes
can you all get a hole in that
congregation i don't think you can
um can you get a whole
just pop back in 28 days later i would
say almost no chance
do i know that that means that i'm
telling you that i would recommend to my
friend
that they have to be a single parent for
a season yeah i know and that
really is hard um
but what the most important thing you've
got to do here
is number one you got to kill this
fantasy right
it doesn't exist anymore as it once was
and the second thing you've got to do
is you've got to get somebody to walk
alongside you and make sure
you have on paper what
he's going to have to do to earn the
privilege
to be your husband to earn the privilege
to parent that child in in proximity
because what happens is you have a
feeling like i'm just gonna know
and as you mentioned it's just gonna
kind of slowly slip back to the way it
was
right and you're going to feel crazy and
if he truly is an addict which who knows
man i'm not a psychologist so i'm not
going to say anything else about that
there is some master manipulation going
on right
and there is some extraordinary
gaslighting there's some giftedness
in getting people to believe that um
you're the crazy one not them right
right any answer to why in the world
were you holding hands with my 13 year
old daughter other than
i screwed up bad and i'm i i i
just screwed up not well you know i was
trying to live through a fantasy that i
had when i was a kid
anything other than that is somebody not
taking responsibility
um anyway i could harp on that all day
long all that to say is i want you
really please amanda get with somebody
get with two people get with three
people
who will sit down with you and really
craft
almost in stone what these boundaries
are gonna look like
someone who's gonna be able to say to
you out loud like i am now
what was is no more and any relationship
moving forward is something that y'all
are gonna have to recraft and rebuild
together
because it's all different after this
okay
okay it's different after this can it be
good i think so i do but does he have a
lot of work to do
yes and the final thing is this isn't to
you this is to anybody
leading any sort of organization with
you can't have these tribunals where you
agree to this or i'm going to tell on
you
you can't bring in authorities
every time bring in
social workers and people to be with the
kids every time
investigate stuff make sure it's right
these little side deals this little
nonsense goes on and
on and on and the forest fire of this
trauma rages
on for generations stop it if you're a
church
if you're a school if you're a daycare
whatever you happen to be
you're a coach you signed up to have
kids in your presence
which means you signed up to protect
children
and a 28-day visit to nashville
is not going to keep your kids safe cops
will
police officers will therapists will
social workers will
well i'm sorry amanda that wasn't
directed at you but here's the deal
that's okay
here's the deal um to everybody
listening
um a man is in a situation where
somebody has dropped a bomb in her world
and amanda i'm heartbroken for you i
wish i had something else i could say
i'm heartbroken for you
and it's going to be a hard 20 21 for
you
um i'll be thinking about you i want you
to keep us posted
please please circle back shoot me an
email let me know how it goes
and to her husband if he happens to be
listening to this
you're not going to weaponize this
situation you're not going to go to war
with your wife you're not going to be
dramatic you screwed
up you hurt a kid
you're not well and you've got a long
road ahead of you